the month of may is asian american and
pacific islander heritage month
recognizing the culture and history
within the community while they have the
highest rate of business ownership of
all minorities asian business owners
faced a number of issues brought on by
the pandemic mary jane bellies explains
how many are striving still to stay open
the pandemic brought on unique
challenges for the asian american
pacific islander business community
family owned cmc boutique has been in
business for over 20 years selling
filipino traditional clothing also
surviving the 2008 recession and now
pandemic when the economic you know
downfall kind of happened
people didn't people lost their homes so
they couldn't buy furniture anymore so
we had to
my mom had to figure out how to change
the business because we didn't want to
lose the business similar struggles echo
for new business owners genus which
provides lab services in the valley
opened in january their main concern
inflation we don't feel that there's
enough opportunities for business owners
like us
there's been a challenge with employment
recruitment sunny vinuya from the office
of small business advocacy says the
resiliency of these businesses to keep
going speaks volume of the culture
diversity and contributions to las vegas
every time i talk to a business owner
their number one concern was actually
their employees that is such an amazing
thing to see it's the small business is
truly still the backbone of our
community and while the asian community
is still reeling in the effects of the
pandemic business owners say the
community support makes all the
difference but post pandemic it's been
the the future is very
hard to predict now we you know it we're
trying to get by with the resources that
we have and something that my mom and my
dad and i always talk about at the end
of the day is the relationships we build
with our customers and they end up
turning into like family friends
lifelong friends we keep in touch mary
jane vallieza live local now